pison open up
that's the motto of europe's new capital
of culture
a symphony composed for the occasion and
videos projected on the walls of
buildings created a magical atmosphere
during the opening show
while a tightrope walker seems to float
over the marketplace to the cathedral
and bells sound in saint bartholomew's
cathedral for the first time in 70 years
the old ones were melted down during the
second world war
i'm happy that even more people are
going to visit the city this year and we
will get to talk to them
and i think it's good that there are so
many events for children and adults
i think it's a unique opportunity for
the city
this one-time gray industrial city has
undergone a major facelift since the end
of communism at the beginning of the
1990s
prison is home to 170 thousand people
making it the fourth largest czech city
in the historic center listed buildings
surrounding one of europe's biggest
market squares bear witness to pearson's
former prosperity
we would like to show that creativity is
the main
driver for the change and also it's an
asset that we need to work with to keep
person an inspiring place to live and to
to visit
pierson is known throughout the world
for its beer pilsner which was first
brewed here in 1842
half a million people visit the pilsner
or quail brewery every year
our cellars are built of sandstone
after fermentation we store the beer and
oak casks here at a temperature of four
to six degrees celsius
that's what defines the quality of our
beer
and it's the key to our success
in the 19th century 260 citizens of
prison joined forces to build the cellar
vaults which stretched four kilometers
they also hired joseph call the bavarian
brewmaster who introduced a new
technology for fermentation at low
temperatures and brewed the first
pilsner
pilsen's best known artist is yeri tunka
he was one of europe's top animation
filmmakers
to mark the start of the city's year as
capital of culture and exhibition
showcases the full spectrum of his work
painting puppet making film and
illustrations
who was often described as the walt
disney of eastern europe based his art
on the czech puppet theater tradition
most of his films were made to appeal to
adults who have managed to preserve a
child-like view of the world
government censorship of animation films
was not as strict as it was for feature
films involving actors
that was an advantage and offered my
father more freedom to realize his ideas
staley kept on coming into conflict with
the regime but he always retained his
artistic freedom for him self-censorship
was out of the question
the authorities only realized during
preparations for the events in 2015 that
austrian architect adolf lewis had also
left his mark on the city
he designed 13 apartments in prison
during the 1920s and 30s
many of them have been lovingly restored
if you look at the interiors the main
axis and the subsidiary axis are always
symmetrical
and another thing that's typical of
adolf lewis's work is that he didn't use
any artistic ornamentation
only organic ornamentation
does help easy here
the wallpaper in this former office has
been restored but the furniture is not
original
the apartments are already a popular
tourist attraction
piss and open up
it's a motto which is intended to change
the city for good